you know i know this is a big part of
your advocacy but
once you're out on a bike and you're not
in a in an uber
or a taxi or a train or whatever you
have a tactile relationship with the
neighborhoods that you're
that you're kind of navigating through
and it really
changes the frame with which you
interact with those
neighborhoods and the people that live
there that you you
you hit the nail on the head is that in
truth it's not even about the bike
right it is literally about re-framing
the relationship you have to the place
you live
right right i mean that is and and
really for
especially in challenged communities you
know
um there's a disconnect you make to the
geography you live in some ways
right you know you just you teleport in
and teleport out right and you live in
your house
right instead of living in your
community right um
and there are lots of reasons for that
and and but that's exactly right it
reframes a relationship to the place you
live
um you know and in a really in a big
picture way
you know isn't the the the history
of of of racism the history of the way
that
xenophobia you know and the history of
you know gender bias is actually all
about limiting mobility
like it's just you know or controlling
the body like if you
really think about it in the in those
gross terms controlling the body
right limiting mobility has really been
always the point
so so the bike itself actually
represents this initial
breakthrough in terms of creating
mobility like it's about mobility moving
through your neighborhood moving around
the city with freedom
right as you may get like as you want to
in a self-propelled manner
right um and and so the symbolism of
that is is really big right yeah it's
transgressive in that regard when you
when you
juxtapose that or contextualize it
against
what happened in chicago and what was it
1919
yeah yeah when the when you know the the
black person
walked down the beach and crossed that
imaginary line into the white beach and
it caused all those riots like
this is the evolution of that in
in you know in in a way to to you know
deconstruct those
those boundaries yeah that are not like
you know they're they're
invisible boundaries and that's and that
really is
insightful i think is and instead you're
one of the few people who actually know
that like i think that's even in terms
of us
uh putting this in the context of
history well this is the generational
piece of it right
um is that that that 1919 event
uh and one of the things i point to that
a lot is because i'm always saying
to people that you have to realize that
this issue of outdoors and equity
is really important because one of the
first great
riots around race in this country
started over an imaginary line on a
beach in lake michigan
right um around this access to public
space
who has a right to be where um and it
could cost you your life
that was that and and that was the first
one but there's been multiple
versions of that same thing and more
recently
um when you look at the uh the last
desegregated spaces in america were
public green spaces
for public pools and as a matter of fact
white america in saint louis or
milwaukee kansas city detroit
rather than let black people in public
pools in those spaces
they'd rather they shut them down they
shut them down i mean
all you have to do is study the history
of public pools in america and it's
it's it's it's literally a history of
race relations
that's incredible there's a woman called
bonnie soy who wrote a book called why
we swim
she was on the podcast and a big part of
that book is about that and it's super
fascinating
you know i grew up in the the washington
dc metropolitan area i was originally
from michigan
and and and uh one of the things i
realized when we moved to washington
is there aren't that many pools there
used to be you know every
where in in the midwest there's pools at
all the high schools for the most part
right
and suddenly there aren't why not well
it all goes back to
that very thing that you're speaking
about yeah no i i think and and that's
again a really just the kind of the
point of
you know why public green space why
outdoors
represents something very significant
relative our fight around racism like
that
that's exactly right and i think again
we don't you know even now
you know the we we can actually predict
all significant disparities by zip code
it doesn't matter disparities in health
care disparities in education
disparities in income
education educational attainment you can
predict every one of those
by zip code in america right now
and and that is grounded in the work
that was done
for segregation beginning in the early
1900s as well you know the initial
things around redlining
all flowed from the fha you know
mortgages so from federally
backed mortgages that was the beginning
of it right created those delineations
and
this city is no different than that it
was all around space and land
yeah yeah this idea that uh
that black bodies in public natural
spaces have always been managed and
controlled
um strikes people
um in a counter-intuitive way because
when you think of outdoor spaces or
public parks
the kind of knee-jerk reaction at least
you know me being a white dude is there
open spaces like they're open to
everybody what are you talking about so
it requires
a more kind of nuanced historically
grounded that's right
you know education to understand why
they're not as open as one might
uh suspect so talk a little bit about
you know
what that means well the you know the i
think the
you know the first thing you know that
you describe right away is this this
they are they are public but they are
controlled um
that we've we've done a lot of things
and and there's two pieces to me and one
of the pieces i think that
we often miss is that you know the the
movement of of black people from the
south to the north
all happen in one window of time right
so the great migration happens
you know really but between 1950 and
1970
let's call right and and when all those
people moved here they were outdoors
people that's one thing i said they were
they was where black people connected to
the land they farmed
fundamentally they fished they hunted
you know there was there was a
connection to the land there's a long
legacy of that right
um and even in washington dc area as
soon as you're not in dc
you're in the country you're in virginia
you're in west virginia you're america
you know
you know all so they were people
connected to the land beginning in the
in the late 60s early 70s you start to
see this
collection of people in cities right and
the first thing they did was control
where black bodies could go
so they actually created areas that
where you could live in places you
couldn't live
right and then and then those parks
right we wound up patrolling
controlling right they they weren't safe
in that regard
and the other thing that simultaneously
happens
is the the beginning of creating the
identity of blackness as urban
right right the idea that urban and
black is synonymous
that's exactly is a new thing it's a new
thing i mean we
only but it's only new if you think 40
years is new see so a world enough to go
that's
new but you know what i mean like that
kind of new would be you know that's
what i say one of the one of the
the negative things about the internet
is history is what happened last week
you know and that's that's how anything
older than that is prehistory
and um so so in but you're absolutely
right
the last 40 50 years has been the
creation
where we when you say urban you could
mean black and as a matter of fact
usually when people say urban they mean
black right
um and so that is that's a new creation
and that grounding of identity is really
been based on the fact that
policing geography banking housing has
all been about controlling black bodies
into very specific geography right
and they're dense they're not green you
know it hasn't been a commitment to
using natural space as a necessary
need for well-being which is how we talk
about it right now right
you know um and and so that's really
significant
and simultaneously you know we get the
the growth
of the of the environmental movement you
know as we see at the sierra clubs and
you know those organizations all pop up
out of the 60s
and i think that though that was really
white america's response to black power
like you know you know that you look at
that's interesting you know what i mean
when does when does the women's movement
start the black movement start the
chicano american movement latinx
whatever we call it that time
when does that when does the gay
movement start that all those movements
start
when 65-75 right when does this movement
emerge
as we know it same window of time same
window of time
and so it's it's a it's just an
interesting way that that happens and
then
as this simultaneously happens we get
the growth of like
like outdoors is the lone adventure
event you know adventurer you know you
need a lot of gear and it's
recreation and that's what we've grown
in the last
you know 50 years too right and i and
that's what i'm i'm that guy right right
you know i get that you know he joked
about that you know you know the rooftop
rack
bike on the front you know this so all
of a sudden
you know this way that we've cultivated
it now
is very different than than what it used
to be
and um and because these are
fundamentally socially
oriented events and really outdoors is
fundamentally a social pursuit
we have to acknowledge america is
socially segregated that
fundamentally america is socially
segregated so one of the things that
black people brown people do
when they're not at work is they
organize with other black and brown
people
like it's like a recuperative strategy
because i got to be in white america all
day like that's where you were like you
know
so i asked so the way that i balance
that is when i have my social options
they're fundamentally you know oriented
towards whatever whoever your people are
right and so so outdoors as we see it as
recreation
social this so what is it black people
do when they when they they don't
hang out with white people right right
or they don't do that
i mean the the trope of like black
people don't camp
black people don't swim they don't ride
mountain bikes or go surfing
um and then the kind of legacy of that
notion gets baked into the next
generation of black people who
believe that that is the case and don't
understand that there are external
forces that have
created that reality and young people
especially because you know that's one
thing i think working with young people
is that young people are always looking
for authenticity
right you know what i'm saying like they
want to do what's they're keeping it
real
like that is real for them they want to
keep it real they want to align with
their identity what they
and so if you look at young black kids
you know with
you know outside you know with they they
go i don't do that you know that's what
they do i'm aligning with what blackness
is
right i'm aligning with those things
that validate that identity that i have
for myself
right um and so that is that's part of
it and their parents are the first
generation of people disconnected from
outdoors
right so so they don't do it either and
and if
your parent isn't taking you that but
but as far as even the black people
don't camp thing what's interesting
is simultaneously and there's and
there's documentation for that
here um as black people did camp
like you look at the 60s 70s even the
80s there there were
and there's hardly any black people here
that's when minneapolis is not like you
know
it's definitely in d.c might not even be
denver i don't know
but um but i'm just saying that i think
that um there are there is documentation
of lake front properties that were that
were
actually populated by all black families
from the twin cities
right lake adney that's what it's called
that literally
and it's in the minnesota so and i know
these families of those families who
who summered at lake adney mm-hmm right
right
and they did that i mean so it's kind of
a it's similar to
uh the history of manhattan beach and
what's going on there in los angeles
right now with the reparations that's
exactly that's an amazing story right
you know but even even in um uh martha's
vineyards
you know there's a legacy right yeah
right right i mean it's still a black
haven if you got the cash
if you got the cash but but the idea of
a black haven at martha's vineyard
in 1940 1950 like people don't know
you know what i mean that that's what
i'm saying yeah even in the poconos
they now know because you know obama
goes there or whatever but
that's right it's like as a minor right
right they don't know that there's
actually a long
legacy of that happening and and you
know i mean that's like
and there were actually um uh state
parks for black people in georgia
wow until desegregation i mean it like
so that's one segregated black park
segregated a segregated state park
outside atlanta near stone mountain yeah
i mean you know what i mean so so this
is like so that kind of
is that's what i mean it was black
people know black people did do that
matter of fact there's there's a legacy
of black people being deeply engaged in
those
activities you know up until this kind
of
new urban focus in terms of what it
means and
and you know the part about that too
that that i would say that's
that is that is interesting is that
there's there's always been parallel
universes for black america
like that's that's the way i remember it
too is you think about
you know and professionally if you think
there's the journalists association
there's a black journalist association
there's the american bar association
national bar association
so there's this way where black life in
some regard
emulated white life only blank yeah well
the marginalization
forces that that impulse to create their
own communities
that's exactly right and so we had these
parallel universes of
all these different things going on all
the time
it's always been that way so there's
always been a black outdoor movement
even now there's a black rvers like
like that like that's how no right now
you go google it
black rvers it is it's a real thing of
black people that
rv that connect to each other and get
out well there's also all these
these cool kind of um you know black
communities about the outdoors like
non-profits or community-based
organizations that are cropping up like
outdoor afro and
diversify outdoors and melanin base camp
like
yeah you know so that's happening in no
small part
i would imagine by the work that you're
doing to try to create
advocacy but so much of it it would seem
you know social media kind of has its
pluses and minuses but
um the way i see it i'm interested in
what you think about this
is that you know hip-hop culture
predominates as you know the largest
cultural force
in america or perhaps across the world
and the influence
of that on young people is beyond
profound right but at the same time
you do have amazing black voices that
are in
the outdoor space who are out there
killing it and creating a
different and new type of role model for
the young black person to model
themselves after
well and you know the the the modeling
well let me i'm not casting aspersions
on hip-hop
i'm just saying they're different things
i think that you know the thing about
hip-hop you know two things about
hip-hop hip-hop
ultimately became this actual very
shared experience for our black youth
and white youth
like like that's one of the things i
think that is a is a
shared kind of interesting experience
for them
because aesthetically you know i feel
like it compared to when i was a kid i
feel like you can
you can no longer turn radio stations
and go who's listening
right because you could do that for a
very long time you knew the audience
always but you can't do that as easily
you can't you could not see a young
person's
clothes and go are they black or white
so their style is very similar
right you know there's a there's a much
more shared social reality that our
young people
have and him 100 percent is part of that
right hip hop is a huge part of that
that's what i'm saying right so so hip
hop you know their
the impact is in that regard is really
interesting the other thing that hip hop
did
what was was um um teach people
the idea that that i converted in
vertically integrate my own money
right i mean as much as i can be an
artist i can be the producer
i can be the label yeah as a matter of
fact i'm gonna distribute this [ __ ]
myself right
into the vertical integration right i
mean everything right
so so so so the young people now go i
can be a corporation
tomorrow you know there's there's a
piece of that that is really
interestingly different i think if you
talk to
black america and even even adults that
are over 45
you know they have a much more
traditional trajectory in terms of how
they would get to success
right go to college like what are the
pathways go to college get the right
degree get in corporate america you
do this ascension right a very which is
all about fitting in
or like that's right as you're told or
checking some questions yeah
assimilation was a fundamental strategy
until hip-hop
right they like they and so not only did
hip-hop go against that then the
internet
you know came along and allowed them to
actually have the tool
to do it themselves and and it's and it
just really
um changed the way that they they saw
the world and kind of their identity so
i think
hip-hop owes that i think the outdoor
movement you know
fueled by young people that the
the thing that they decided to do and i
and i do know the young people and and i
i know
um rue map at outdoor afro i mean i know
the people
that diversify outdoors i mean these are
people i know but i'm gonna say
that i think they were more innovative
in some regards than i was
right because i do think they're the new
guard and i think that they focus their
energies on changing the narrative
like they were literally like yes we do
like that's that that should be the
website yes black people do
because that was kind of you know we we
do climb you know oh no we we do do this
we do do that
and they then challenge the system
against the fact that they had to
assimilate